welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down genv episode
5 last week made you Tech yourself
before you wrecked yourself and this
week starts to unveil a whole truth the
entry gives us some answers about what's
going on whilst also throwing a couple
of curve balls our way throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the Easter eggs hidden details and also
talking about that ending to discuss
where things could be going for episode
6 next week heavy spoilers ahead so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
then I highly recommend that you check
out now if you enjoyed the video please
hit the thumbs up and make sure you
subscribe for breakdowns on the show
every week without the way huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
genv episode 5 so we pick up immediately
after last week in which we saw Sam
going wild at Dr kadosa just before
things were about to man up we watched
as they pulled a One Division and then
cut out a scene even in the opening
recap we get some One Division inspired
stuff and change things up and mess
about with what Marie said here's the
line in episode
we'll and here's the line how it's
played in the recap we're going to make
it I think Kate might even be messing
with reality as a whole but we'll talk
about this more later on in the video
we're
sorry we're sorry you will talk about it
in just a bit but we wake up with her
and Andre with stuff dripping on his
face which he sees coming from the room
above revealed to be a girl with a blow
hole I kind of hope that her in the Deep
they get to know each other cuz I think
those guys could work out now in the
comics there were lots of fish women
during the herogasm arc and I wonder if
it's sort of giving us the student dorm
version of that when we cut of the
couple we can see the guy vibrating his
hand which is something that a lot of
speeders can do in the comics eard Thorn
actually used to use it to kill people
and it's something the DCU version of
The Flash did when when fighting the
kryptonians yeah he's well he's well
using the vibrations to make a VI but
you know you know what I'm saying and in
the end it completely soaks the ceiling
also is that is that a llama this is
actually someone known as Sloan who it
turns out is actually a student guessing
this is the Gen VY version of Beast or
something or a Villain Like cheetah or
or just an actual llama you never know
these days either way pulling Maverick
along we missed this in our first
breakdown but we did learn that he's
actually translucent son he appeared
during season 2 episode 1 and was
present at his dad's funeral sitting in
the front row you also see a room that's
got a fire breather with fire breath
being something that several Comic
characters can do we also saw that
orderly getting fire breed at them in
the woods which could potentially be
linked in with this kid also there's
this weird sort of scaly metallicy
feathery thing just to the left in front
of the girl who looks like she's wearing
what's dragon scale armor don't know
what's going on with that but it might
be linked in with the fire breather and
if you have more of an idea then drop it
in the comments below anyway they
stumble in to see Marie and Jordan in
bed together and the former kind of goes
back and forth over what's happened with
them as we know Jordan can change gender
and the pair don't even remember what's
happened with each other in the room we
can also catch a mave poster on the wall
and a cut out of most of the seven above
the bed C Emma who's still in giant
Cricket mode which makes me think the
entire thing after Sam was a complete
blackout since then the group have spent
days in a sort of state of just being
out of it which is why Emma never bought
shrinking down we see videos from the
party on the Tik Tok of someone called
super kid and can catch rat girl and
Justin returning to Sam also chugs a keg
of beer which is normal size to her due
to her being giant Captain OB is there
but none of them remember anything which
we lat to learn was brought on by Kate
we've actually had hints towards her
messing with people's memories which is
why Luke didn't remember what happened
with his brother during episode 3 when
she was there comforting him it was
almost like she was pushing him down a
certain Road Sam was still alive but but
Luca thought he died likely Jud toate
telling him to forget and then create
that memory Jordan immediately starts
questioning things and we see his K also
drinks from a can of Turbo Rush next to
Andre we can also catch a dawn of the 17
and a poster of staright up beside
Jordan's head cut to Emma and Marie
sitting next to a superhero Square sign
with the former also wearing a god hu
hoodie for the show they made at a
university whereas in the comics it was
more like Xavier school for gifted
youngsters as we get away a shut of the
room we can also see another dawn of the
seven stand this time featuring none
other than Starlight Emma says no I've
known ever since the Buster Beaver
incident and Buster Beaver is something
that we've seen in the show before this
is where black Ando hit out during
season 3 and it's cartoon characters are
what he saw in his Visions clearly this
is a big staple of a lot of people's
childhoods and I wonder if Sam might
hide out there at some point now he
shows up here but it becomes clear from
the memory thing that none of them
remember him or even know he exists
whereas in the past it was just Luke who
was wiped out here we see they don't
recall him at all they made you forget
Kate's obviously been someone that
they've greatly used to Aid them and we
see how they tend to go to soups that
can help further their ends this is in
the case and Marie and also Rufus 2 who
I was under the impression that he was
the one who caused the blackout he's
clearly a weaker kind of Kate though as
Marie had to go in close in order for it
to work he also couldn't mess with their
memories which is something that Kate's
power set includes also like how Sam
doesn't know what Tik Tok is because the
guy's been in the woods and Sage Grove
for probably most of his life maybe you
saw us on TV or Tick Tock or something
Tick Tock now Maran sense at Sam's
blooded is and his under his fingernails
and she can also sense when Emma's
period's coming too this was what ended
up bringing on her powers and it does
sort of tie this together now outside
Kate plays so long she can't remember
anything but she recalls text night
being at the party I doubt he'd show up
to this kind of party but to be fair
there's probably a lot of holes that
need filling that one on no girls back
however her remembering this shows that
it's just an act as everyone else has
nothing but complete blank spots Andre
also says that he blew off the Haley
Miller Show who we met in episode two
when she was interviewing Marie she also
pretends to not know who Sam is but she
would of course remember him from what
happened with Luke Kate knew about Sam
through her relationship with him and
thus would likely remember him from
Beyond the last few days now outside we
see Dusty who's one of those kids that
looks 14 but he's actually 28 you know
you know them you knew them at school
and Rufus gets the blame and sort of
becomes a big red herring worked on me
cuz I thought it was him too but I still
don't know how he's walking around
without a dick and I don't think Theory
time will ever give us the answers to
that makes me glad though after what he
did to Kate and as we theorized his name
was based on ruy we find out he did
something horrific when he was with her
and yeah to be fair explode the guy
balls as well to me it's one of the
darkest things that's ever been brought
up in the show with her being convinced
on camera to consent to what he was
doing and this might also explain why
she wears gloves and this is so she at
least has control over her power this
trauma may make her want to be
restricted on inflicting it on others
and we do know what happened with her
brother however we see as she's still
willing to control people and shed sort
of doing the same thing with her though
she doesn't possess the powers what she
does though is possess a position of
power and she's telling her to do stuff
and then she's then going on to do that
herself shows that power doesn't exist
just with the superpowers and that
humans can take it on too and mimic what
they see around them lots of complex
themes going on in this episode and we
also discover Kate's got a dark side to
her anyway at the words we see Kos say
Shook and learn that he's actually
working on a virus he also requests
Marie to study her abilities and it all
ties into what I think's going on now
that takes us in a few time a few time
got a sore throat so do sound as good
what do you mean always sounded [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] so as we talked
about on our breakdowns before the risk
of superpowered kids turning into Super
Villains is rising exponentially the
corporate attitude of V is growing
greedier and greedier with more and more
soups lining up to step in the place of
the ones who step out of line in the
last couple of decades there weren't
that many soups so the company didn't
have as much power over them now though
the characters can easily be replaced
and thus they don't value the soups that
they have as much it's also the fact
that so many kids were injected with bee
Who Came From Bad homes that this gave
them bad upbringings and also traumatic
pasts some have powers that can't be
controlled and to be honest if you had
these abilities would you listen to the
law I doubt many would and the centers
like Sage Grove and so on have to be
created to keep them all in check
however the soups are becoming more and
more dangerous and thus the powers that
be have been looking for other ways to
control them by the sounds of this this
virus could nullify their kind and wipe
them out on mass across the entire world
this is something that we saw in the
comics without also being a frequency
that could cause their heads to explode
this put them in massive danger with the
good soups of course being affected by
two Juda Marie's abilities I think they
may use her as a way to spread the virus
quickly because if she can contaminate
blood then it could only ship worldwide
she could also be selective of who got
what and thus could pick and choose
which soups died now we also hear has a
benefactor but don't learn who this is
and I think it might be one of the
higher up humans that we've met before
my guess right would be that it's St
Edgar as he's been Ed from his company
and is kind of powerless to stop
homelander this would give him the
ability to do it but it also could be
Vic Newman who is running her own
endgame she likely wants to be the one
who ends up in the White House and the
soups trying to stop her would cause a
lot of issues th she needs a way that
she can Reign them in and a virus like
this would provide Limitless value if
the soups ever rose up she could use it
as part of a campaign and help keep her
in power as she'd be seen as a savior
also I'm wondering if this virus was
inspired by real world events and yeah
we're going to see how it plays out cuz
they are clearly focused on it now kosa
wants to experiment on Marie but shedy
forbids it and again this ties in The
Mangler Health Clinic line turns out
this school is a [__] manga Health
Clinic he was a Nazi scientist that
carried out human experiments which
kadosa himself is also trying to do okay
to get the feeling we might get a sort
of carry moment come the end where Marie
just unleashes and goes completely wild
I can definitely see it just being like
a blood bath with her looking similar to
how Carri did as well so yeah lots of
things going on there and that's end the
the time just one Echo this time cuz it
gets a bit annoying now back at the
campus we see Emma gaining Fame and she
passes by a turbo Rush vending machine
Marie and Jordan have a bit of an
awkward conversation too due to him
shutting it down and refusing to discuss
what happened spotting Rufus with with
Shetty Maurice says she doesn't trust
her and potentially she was there when
they got wiped these memories may be
starting to seep in with her body
remembering even if she doesn't this is
something that they discuss with K2 and
Luke obviously had this with his visions
of Sam as well catching up to Rufus they
say he's being impersonated by a shape
shifter named Benny but that doesn't
mean that he's out of the hot water yet
getting back to his room we see Andre
locks him in together and he does this
by pulling bars across the doors and
windows cut back episode one and you
might remember Marie asking why they
were locked in with this clearly
spelling out it for security reasons
when she first entered the school we saw
this on the door to with her being
almost like that maximum security room
this is clearly because of how powerful
the soups are and they might need to
contain and shut them down quickly going
back to that first episode if you look
closely you can actually catch the bars
just above the window which we see
dropped down here n rufa says that Kate
attacked him and brings up jamanji which
is what she told them to do during the
first three episodes [__] jongi and
every time you swing yell jamanji
sound good can't remember what one it
was cuz I like watched them all together
but don't ask me it was a long day that
day I Kate being able to get rufers to
do this shows how powerful she is in
comparison to him she can out and out
tell people to do stuff whereas he kind
of has to hypnotize them and just make
them black out Andre blacks out too at
this point and he comes to an AV Burger
which has been mentioned through out
most of the series want to get some V
Burger I could kill from okir
homelanders grinning on the drink and
Emma smiling too after making it to the
top 100 her giant stuff's popping up
which goes against what her mother wants
which again feels like it's bringing at
her rebellious side against Emma as wall
we also see that Queen M poster again
which was a parody of 2017's Wonder
Woman there's also big crazy love too
which featured another miniature hero in
the unforgettable termite once you see
his scenes you'll never you never forget
them now after getting Marie to admit
she likes Jordan Emma discovers her
drivein shirt which comes from the one
that she and Sam hit out at known as
Stardust this is a Planet Hollywood
parody packed out with lots of soups
movies now elsewhere we get one of the
most creative scenes in the boy history
with Sam taking out lots of puppet SWAT
team members during this C of puppet
version of Emma who's wearing the shirt
that he really started to like her in
the Stardust stuff would be a really fun
memory for him and though he's seen her
in other clothes yeah this would be what
he he would imagine her wearing I'm
guessing either way it shows the dangers
of the soups with a teenager taking out
highly trained men this is all spurred
on by his mental health issues which is
something the comics have tackled before
with both moonnight in the Sentry here
Sam goes into an almost childlike
version of the world and the puppets
allow him to carry out horrendous acts
without him feeling the impact so funny
just watching him rip these puppets
apart and we also get the idea yeah that
is actually bulletproof I have a single
dad with two daughters
are [__] hell mate just it's got such
a dark sense of humor and though we
can't show it when we see what actually
went on it's pretty messed up now back
with Marie and Emma they start to
suspect the school may be involved and
we learn that shed's instructing Kate
again stem is dress so we can also catch
a big crazy love one poster and also
little mini clothes for when she shrinks
down she's got some really tiny ones and
even toddler dresses as her decid
depends on how much that she vomits now
em asks why Marie's scratching her neck
like Tyrone bams and a Amazonia y youall
got any of those boy season 4 trailers
yet it turns out some people aren just
paranoid and we actually learned that
they've all got tracking devices in them
implanted Under the Skin the entire
group has them again highlighting how it
goes just beyond Rufus this is a big
conspiracy involving the words and after
Marie goes to sky K's neck she then
decides to wipe her this all happens in
Andre's room and we can catch a polarity
poster on the wall this is far as movie
Area 51 which was actually mentioned
earlier in the season on TV we can also
see one of starlight's skincare
commercials and as we know she had a big
time with these in vort now we then C to
Jordan who's talking with Maverick about
how they've had to wrestle with jender
in the past all the people she's dated
she had to fit into whether they wanted
to be with a guy or girl thus Jordan's
not able to really be themselves and
they have to fit themselves into a box
in order to make the other person happy
now Maverick then brings up hiding in
toilets which as we know yeah his dad
does too where he then comes out and if
you look on the wall you can see a
bulletin board containing homelander
Maven also Crimson Countess Marie does
remember how she got her cut and also
the conversations from before that she
had with Jordan however Kate of course
hasn't managed to get to the rest yet so
Jordan ST stand like what what the
hell's going on now from here we quick
we quickly get those answers and we cut
to shete stirring some tea which I kind
of feel is riffing on get out this was
used as a way to hypnotize people and
it's clear that Kate's under her control
again it speaks to who the true power is
as you know this this isn't involving
her having powers but with her being a
corporate leader she's clearly able to
control her actions the soups like Kate
could easily kill their masters but
they're kept in place by superficial
things this is stuff like popularity and
being accepted which shedy also uses to
keep Kate in line whether Kate knows a
lie is spiraling out of control and
can't keep on top of all the people that
she's been wiping in the early episodes
Kate was saying how her Pusher abilities
were causing a strain and I wonder if
she'd been just constantly wiping Luke
and from here we cut a Burger Shack
which is when we see Amma meeting up
with Sam the tagline talks about a tasty
burger which might be riffing on jewels
from Pulp Fiction
mhm this is a tasty burger
as she goes in we see a payback poster
and also one for shockwave's movie raced
to death Shockwave actually died during
season 2 with his movie poster having an
ironic twist to it now he was actually a
parody of Wally West and he replaced a
trainers the fastest soups at this point
Sam confirms Kate made looke forget his
brother and we then cut to her traveling
out to Andre's out in his room we see
there's also a Golden Boy poster showing
how he kind of still hangs over the PIR
on the TV we them watching a show called
mesmerizer which is such a cool meta
joke inserted in the show you've
actually seen mesma before in the main
series and he was actually played by
Haley Joel Osmond he was a child star
like mesma was too and he starred in
this TV show during the 1990s here he
played a Psychic Detective and then
became a member of teenage kicks
unfortunately though he started using
his powers for bad and got caught up in
insider trading mesma was cut out of by
V and he also lost custody of his
daughter with him basically being a soup
that show you could be replaced I think
him using his powers this way is
reflected in Kate who would also end up
getting in trouble too now Andre wants
the pair to just both leave the school
and though she loves this dream she
knows that it's not possible shedy has
her completely under control and no
matter what she's not going to let her
leave they still have a happy moment
though but unfortunately it's cut short
by what's happening with Rufus jump to
him watching mesmerizer as well which is
when Marie and Geor burst into the room
Dusty backs him up though and says that
it's not him and he can also catch a
post of a black noir as well right
beside him is one for a different drink
by a train and hey I'm just getting used
to Turbo Rush mate what what the hell is
this at this point we also see Emma
calling Marie who then pulls out her
phone it's kind of blurred but you can
see the backgrounds Queen May which I
actually think is a nice little detail
Emma tells them that it's Kate but Andre
busts in which is what leads to Kate
revealing the truth to him we now see
the elements of the previous episodes
revealing the whole truth and it's a
real gut punch for the character to
learn love the shot how we have Andre
crying whereas with Kate we see that her
eyes are bloodshot just gives the idea
that she's a bit of a monster which we
get as the final line as Andre leaves
please understand I didn't you're a
[__] monster to the sound of I Put a
Spell on You it sums up that she's like
a sort of witch playing into the whole
the whole wand and Jean Gray thing now I
really think well Gan gray is not a
witch but you know what I mean you guys
are smart you you watch breakdowns and
learn stuff you know what I'm talking
about now I really think I'm sorry the
these videos are pretty crap on there
but but we'll keep going and I really
think that we're seeing the Bare Bones
of her powers and if she can affect
someone's idea of reality she may be
able to do more like I said earlier
there lots of One Division themes and
I'd love it if they really ramp that up
to show her manipulating people to live
in her view of the world now that
doesn't necessarily mean that she
changes reality but she could alter how
people perceive things makes you wonder
if she can implant memories as well as
Luke thought that his brother had died
he'd surely have to see this or hear
about it I think that's the case and
yeah it's starting to make me think she
might be one of the keys to the show
potentially she might even end up wiping
shed's memories and destroying all
knowledge of the words as we close the
season out think more likely though that
we'll see the virus getting made which
will then be something that plays into
the main show a worry with Gen V was
that it wouldn't really matter but I
think with this element it'll easily pay
off down the line it's such a major
factor when it comes to controlling the
soups and it's a really good way to take
things into the future now as are my
thoughts on this episode I I think it
was probably the weakest so far but you
know that they're batting at such a high
average that it's difficult to really
fault it had some really good sound up
moments in it and all of the stuff with
Sam and the puppets were great which was
then elevated by the general mystery
going on just never been a massive fan
of Amnesia stories and where characters
try and catch up to where they were
originally still though this came with
some brand new knowledge and it took
Kate in a really interesting Direction I
love the way that they've developed
these characters and they really hit a
point where they're deeply layered
people in episode one when she showed up
kissing Luke I I just thought we were
going to be getting another
stereotypical cheerleader type thought
Luke was going to be a jock too but
they've done such interesting things
with them that are I think are really
good I'm super interested in seeing
where the show is going to go next and
it's really got me hooked around this
whole mystery guessing that the entire
school's going to get destroyed but with
the boys you never really know everyone
might even end up getting Senter at
almyra and this is so Vault can come out
on top again and cover it all up so yeah
lots of things to talk about and let me
know your thoughts on the show below
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you'll get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
if you want to get some heavy spoilers
merch we've also also got our t-shirt
line located just below the video that
will let you pick up all kinds of tops
like our two time one lowy one which
we've just dropped so go check that out
the SOA ones House of dragon stuff
Marvel teas and a lot more we drop new
designs on there all of the time so
definitely keep an eye for them and yeah
thank you to everyone who's bought one
as it massively helps us out now if you
want something else to watch you've got
a breakdown on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way huge thank you for sing
through the video I've been Paul let's
see you next time you take care a pce
I'm
out